big things small packages come on let's
just talk about this new ant-man and the
wasp trailer just dropped or as a
recording this will be coming out of day
after it dropped so what let's talk
about it we get a little bit more plot
in this one as you would expect first
trailer was a teaser now I've said in
the past that when there are movies that
I know for certain I'm gonna see after
the first teaser I usually won't watch
more stuff after that because I don't
want stuff to be spoiled and I did break
that rule with this one I think it's
partially because while I do plan to see
ant-man in the wasp it's not one of the
movies I'm like sure or that I expect
you know that plot twists and turns are
really going to be the main feature of
it either so I it's not one where I'm
expecting to be caught off guard or
taken by surprise by the plot so I don't
mind getting more of a sense of it than
I had so this trailer I talked about the
first one I think pretty sure I did
which was fine it you know it reminded
you that it was coming out Evangeline
Lilly looks pretty good I I will say as
sort of my one major negative now what I
what I thought when I saw the first
trailer which is that I wish there was a
clearer distinction between the wasp
suit and the ant-man suit because you
know even though you know the ant-man
has the red highlights and the wasp has
the yellow I wish that maybe if the
yellows have been more vibrant on the
wasp suit or it had just had more color
so it wasn't predominantly black with
just yellow highlights or maybe a little
shift in the design they look they look
too similar to me I wish they did not
look so similar I mean I get why from a
practical standpoint one is based on the
other the texts gonna be similar but
come on but honestly other than that
this trailers a lot of fun I enjoyed
this quite a bit and what it sold me the
most on is the thing that I am kind of
most looking forward to in the new movie
which is new inventive fun ways to
you the size changing gimmick and it
shows that there definitely is a lot
more mileage to be gotten out of this
whole hook that wasn't already explored
in the first film in terms of the stuff
that gets you know shrunk down or made
big again
the way in which it's used the way in
which is using combat and escapes in all
these sorts of things so all that I'd
really made me excited I could go
through all of them I think the one that
made me most go all was the fight scene
in the kitchen when the wasp you know
throws this salt shaker and then hits it
with a growing thing it blocks the door
and it's got just ones into this giant
salt shaker that's awesome I like it so
I'm digging all that and that at this
point is definitely what I'm most
excited to see in this film is to see
more of that more of that inventive
action and the glimpse we got of our
villain the ghost show that there is
probably gonna be some inventive action
there as well because why this is not a
character I know from the comics it's
cool look though I dig her look but
she's not somebody I know so I don't
know her background her or too much
about that but you know seeing her basic
deal which seems to be becoming
incorporeal and then resolidify ababy
sort of basically seems to be Kitty
Pryde skillset its phasing through stuff
but seeing that get used creatively even
in just the trailer so we've got a
creatively fighting villain with
creatively fighting heroes yeah I am
pretty excited to see how these fights
go down and and how they pan out as far
as other things go I was a little
nervous when I saw Michael Pena again
because well I didn't dislike him he was
the kind of characters like yeah you're
fine but when I knew he was coming back
with a sequel and like you're the kind
of guy that can get grading if they
overuse him but I will admit I was
basically smiling when he showed up and
when he had his lines it he's he's
looking much more professional like him
and his him and his crew I'm I have to
wonder if they've like gone
semi-legitimate lie
I have to wonder I don't know if anyone
will get this movie reference any of my
subscribers but I wonder if it's like
the movie sneakers where like they they
are hired to test security systems you
know see if you can break in here they
sort of they have that slightly legit
vibe to them now so I'm a little curious
about that as far as other stuff ooh
Laurence Fishburne and I it makes me
happy that they're acknowledging Goliath
and you know that that was the thing
whether or not we'll actually see him go
giant I'm not expecting that for the
same reason I'm not really expecting
Michael Douglas to suit up and get into
action scenes you know they're just
they're not really built for that and it
possibly pushes credibility to to a
certain degree but who knows and it was
it's very cool to see acknowledged and
it was cool than having their banter
back and forth I really like that Scott
Lang's daughter says you know maybe you
need somebody watching your back a
partner cuz I hope I really really hope
that the emphasis on the relationship
between ant-man and the wasp is as
partners you know in terms of working
together I'm not saying there can't be a
romantic aspect but I really want that
to be secondary I want this to be built
on that I want the the focus of the
relationship to be built on them figure
out how to work together or not
falling in love because I don't care I I
really am a complete you know killjoy
when it comes to romantic subplots in
these sorts of stories but I don't care
it is not what I'm here to watch its it
takes time away from the stuff that I
like I almost never enjoy that that said
I do know that Michelle Pfeiffer is
appearing as the Oise mother as I
believe Janet Van Dyne and I am
interested to see how she will play off
of Michael Douglas and so that's a
relationship I would be interested to
see the romantic dynamic and because I
think it's there's something interesting
to be done with that
as opposed to Evangeline Lilly and Paul
Rudd where it's just gonna be the same
old Oh their antagonist a God they get
along they embracing the kiss at the end
like I don't care but that's me sort of
projecting a fear onto it maybe it won't
do that I expect it will these things
usually do but it's not in the trailer
what's in the trailer I pretty much all
like except for you know my criticism
about wishing the wasp a suit looked
more distinct from ant-man but other
than that this looks like a lot of fun
and I'm way more excited for it now than
I was originally so new trailer for
ant-man of the wasp
did you see it would you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it you can support me on patreon
if you think my stuff is worth
supporting plus there's links on my
other stuff Twitter podcast etc that's
all down on the description so until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]